oh good morning you guys first up
marriage marriage is what brings us
about today we all love that movie right
a new study has found how old you are
when you get married can affect your
risk of getting divorced researchers
found the risk is lower for those in
their 20s but for every year you marry
after the age of 32 the risk of divorce
could go up by 5
now those who married between the ages
of 28 and 32 were the least likely to
get divorced
a
never-before-released whitney houston
song has been bought as an nft for some
big bucks it went for nearly 1 million
dollars at auction now the song was
recorded when whitney was only 17 and it
includes access to the song and a
digital video created by diana sinclair
the teen artist was recently featured in
time and vogue magazines john heather
wow i'm sure sorry mercedes the news
about the divorce rate shook me to my
core i know i know it's exponentially
going up for you john i know wow
mercedes there's a special gift if you
don't get your packages on time for the
holidays what could we get if we don't
get what we're trying to get
this is so great and you can actually
use this as an excuse heineken beer has
got you covered so the beer maker came
up with an iou box complete with a
festive design an iou note and a 16 gift
card to buy a six pack of heineken and
these six bottle shaped slots to fit the
six pack perfectly you can actually
request a box on the heineken iou
website by uploading a screenshot of
your shipping delay and then explaining
the issue heineken is going to let you
know if you're picked and uh then you
can use that as an excuse and say like
i'm sorry but here's some heineken john
heather yeah it said i owe you
headphones like someone's getting
hopefully the
not the old ones right yeah i owe you
some like you know a new oven but
instead here's a beer yeah here's a beer
yeah that seems like it i guess it works
consolation prize it'll hold you over
for a little while
mercedes thank you very much appreciate
it have a good rest of the day
appreciate you bye mercedes good job
guys
still kind of worried about the divorce
rate aren't you only slightly just
kidding let's talk weather sherry sweats
is here at 6 46 good morning sherry good
morning you guys i see so they're
covering their hiney